it's one of those things it's just like
the routine of the season that
when it gets disrupted just like a
two-game series i hated the two-game
series too it's like by the time you
unpack your suitcase you're ready to go
dribbler up the line and simmons will
beat it out singer had nothing to do but
pick the ball up so a one-out infield
hit for simmons
seemed like even his outs i mean we
talked about it as oh for when it was 14
or 15 that he started
about eight of those seemed like they
were lying out to left in the center and
hard hit balls
that's the left and that'll drop in
front of ben and tendy kiriloff has a
hit
two aboard now for ceno
it's just such a big outfield especially
for a guy like attendee who played
the shortest left maybe in all the
baseball in fenway for so long it's one
of those things where
we've we've seen that a couple times in
this series where he's gone he's thought
about an understanding that if this ball
gets past him with the runner on first
this ball is going to the wall and the
run is going to score
here's sono with two on two out
hanging by a thread
the ground ball that's a fair ball down
the left field line
simmons around third he's going to score
and kiralof will be held at third base
and now he's hung up and tagged out
rounded a little bit too far the run
will score
but a mistake on the bases with ceno
driving in a run with a double when the
twins get the first run of the game
tony diaz the third base coach he did
the right thing he held him but he
couldn't get him back to the
base
and as we said tremendous command and
control in the minor leagues 244
strikeouts just 26 walks
and dyson bloops one towards right he is
on and the royals will
get into bailly as they have a speed guy
at first base
[Applause]
royals go with more hit and runs with
one out than they do with nobody out
does take a shot at right field and
that's perfection
gallagher showing
good skills there and the throw
to third base
simmons he'll defend behind second base
trying to keep dyson near
ostedio in at third
ceneaux in it first two on nobody out
showing bunt lays it down pops it up
cino with the catch he'll throw to
second base there's one sim is now
running gallagher back to first base and
this is going to be a triple play
the twins turn a triple play on a bunt
off the bat of lopez
a triple play in kansas city and the
royals had two on nobody out they get
nothing and the twins maintain a
one-nothing lead to the fourth we go on
your home for twins baseball
he's faced him in front of the hole
dugout
another opposite field hit by whit and
he do it going for two and probably not
going to stop there
the royals have a man at third base with
nobody out
watch the right fielder i don't know if
he got his feet mixed up or what but as
he reaches down for this ball
he he twisted and fell right on his face
oh that's kirloff my bad sorry mr garlic
i didn't mean to
do that to you but that's kirloff and
here comes wit
a hard time doubling him up now they
want to somehow some way find a way to
get this run home here ben intended he
has been a good rbi guy of late yeah
he knocks that one to center field for a
hit in comes with to tie the game at one
bentendi since may 22nd
now has 17 rbis in 14 games
yeah second time through he's going to
more off speed for his pitches look at
ben tindy now he he wasn't looking for a
fastball he was just ready for anything
he waited on it he saw it it was a
hanger and he did exactly what you want
to do put an easy swing and knock in a
run to tie it
up and it's a lead off walk well long
inning good job by garlic going up there
and
being disciplined looking for something
he wants
[Applause]
and the ball
rolling away from lopez
and it'll be another infield hit for the
twin shortstop
squaring and dropping down a good punt
and polanco will reach safely a bunt
single
we've seen him try it a number of times
on this road trip and the bunts have all
slowly rolled foul that one stayed in
the grass and now they're loaded up with
nobody out
sees those runners out there loaded he
wants to knock him in he's going to be
aggressive
he gets him with the slider bending down
and away two outs
man i want to i want to be the guy knock
him in but you know what though brady's
gonna say hop i know your tendencies and
i'm going to get you on a chase here so
two key strikeouts for him
well if he can somehow get out of this
is he able to make an adjustment was he
paying attention to what happened to the
guy before him
got him
that hit him that'll get the go-ahead
run in
and larnica got smoked
from the foot
a few games ago
and kind of hobbles his way to first
base again
earlier it was the back foot i'm not
sure where this one got it could easily
have been the front foot it looked like
he tried to jump over it here and
look like maybe got him in the shin or
a little slider that he spiked and hit
him on the outside of that front foot
that smack to left field
going to second
he's got a double and the royals have a
chance oh here they come these guys
never quit and the crowd is behind him
nobody's left the building
that little
change up was floating right in the
middle
lucky wit didn't tie it up with that
swing
but another nice
line drive
in the opening six to five royals when
he hit two home runs
he's hit 27 in his career
against minnesota pitching
you know the first base is open and
gutierrez a younger
less established player on deck you
would think that maybe
it may not give him anything i'm good
they just did
yeah there's no way you can't let salvi
beat you in that situation
[Music]
to simmons
and that ends it and the twins win
another one-run ball game and the
bullpen was nearly perfect
yeah this is a good team win right here
you got to give you you know tip your
cap to those guys coming in on a bullpen
every time that door open they answer
the bell and they did the job and
just enough offense to win a ball game
but
two in a row day off tomorrow happy
flight and get ready for the yankees on
tuesday